I've heard that you have a hole in your
head from one of your stunts is that
true well I was doing a Yugoslavia jump
on the tree yeah and their tree break
huh
then I try to prep my mother tree you
break break break break and the Yugoslav
cameraman was holding a camera like this
yeah if he put down a camera just push
me a little bit yeah I think I would be
safe right who went when he see my four
he put let the camera run away I was so
lucky I know how to floor yeah I fall
like this boom yeah on Andy yes if I
fall I did yeah gone gone that's not
full like this right just just tiny
punch boom then I get out my backpack
the bottom yeah if a hat that I think
I'm dying right if you head first but
you make sure the head hit second okay
then is your injury I don't know I get
up they said don't get up then I then
sat on there I hear my ear poo the blood
comes out Oh Dan done and the hose here
you had a hole in your head two finger
two fingers yeah take these two fingers
I'm Bo I'm bowling with Jackie Chan
oh my god yes yes yes yes yes open like
this like yeah and take the bow bow bow
put the prostate I don't know probably
put the prostate in L glass plastic
throw plastic I'm sorry have a second
says Yugoslavian doctor
[Applause]
cow you gotta get closer next time you
gotta get closer so that I'm really
ready to go anyway that but you're okay
now that they put bone in there is some
plastic you're okay yeah I'm okay no
just when I hear some hi hi boys
my hear my ears get hurt then what are
you doing on this show I've got the most
annoying poisoned television nice
audience yes they're very nice
you
you